♪ (intro music) ♪
Shall we take a look at the first one
that came in, was from @alpharthur:
"Can I ask about any prebuilt binary
for the RTX 2080 GPU on Ubuntu 16?"
That is very specific.
- That is very specific.
- (laughter)
So, I like specific questions,
even if I can't answer them.
(laughter)
So, in this case,
the prebuilt binaries for TensorFlow
tend to be associated
with a specific driver from Nvidia.
So, the version of CUDA that we support
or the version of cuDNN that we support.
So, my recommendation would be
if you're taking a look
at any of the prebuilt binaries,
take a look at what driver
or what version of the driver
you have supported on that specific card.
I'm not an expert on Nvidia cards,
although I love them,
so I don't really know
what's supported by that card, Arthur.
But if you go over here,
like on my laptop,
I've called up some of what Nvidia say
as their TensorFlow system requirements
and the specific versions
of the drivers that they support.
And the one gotcha--
and we had this
in the last segment as well--
that I find one working with GPUs
is that it's easy for you
to go to the driver vendor
and download the latest version.
But that may not be the one
that TensorFlow is built for
or the one that it supports.
So, just make sure
that they actually match each other.
And you should be good to go,
even with that particular card.
Yes. And if you have
warm feelings and excitement
about builds in general for TensorFlow,
we have a great special interest group
specifically focused on that
called SIG-Build.
(Laurence) SIG-Build.
So, I strongly suggest going
to the community section of our GitHub
and checking out the SIG-Build listserv
and joining it and joining
our weekly stand-ups.
Right. So, thanks, Arthur,
for that question.
And the next question
is a really funny one, I think.
How many times
have you been asked this today?
Oh, my God, at least 12.
- At least!
- (laughter)
And then the other flavor of it is,
well, is this is a particular symbol
that I use all the time?
Is this going to also be supported
in TensorFlow 2.0?
And if not, what is changed?
(giggling)
People have invested so much time
building stuff in TensorFlow 1.x,
they don't want it to be deprecated,
- they don't want it to go away...
- (Paige) Understandable.
So, how do we answer it?
"Do my TensorFlow scripts
work with TensorFlow 2.0"?
The sad fact is that probably not.
They would not work
with TensorFlow 2.0 out of the box.
But we have created
an upgrade utility for you to use.
It's automatically downloaded
with TensorFlow 2.0
whenever you download it.
For more information on it
and what in particular it's doing,
you can check out this medium blog post
that I and my colleague Anna created,
as well as this
Upgrade to TensorFlow 2.0 video.
It goes through, and with GIFs,
which is the best communication
medium possible.
It shows you how you can use
the upgrade script on an end file.
So, any sort of arbitrary Python file
or even Jupyter Notebooks--
one of our machine-learning GDEs
created an extension
that will allow you to do that as well.
And it'll give you an export.txt file
that shows you all of the symbol renames,
the added keywords,
and then also some manual changes
if you have to make manual changes.
- (Lawrence) Cool.
- (Paige) Usually, you do not.
So, to see this in action,
we can go and take a look
at this particular text generation example
that we have running a Shakespeare--
well, it takes all of the corpus
of Shakespeare text,
trains against the Shakespeare text
and generates something
that the bard could have
potentially written
should he have had access
to deep learning resources.
(Laurence) "I know you all and will uphold
the wildest unyoked humour
of your [idleness.]"
(Paige) I did not know
you knew Shakespeare.
(Lawrence chuckles)
I actually played Henry IV in high school.
That's amazing.
That's why I love this notebook.
I was Beatrice
in Much Ado About Nothing.
(Laurence) Oh, cool.
While we're on Much Ado About Nothing,
maybe we should go back to the notebook.
Yes, so here's what it looks like
in collab form,
text generation using an RRN
with eager execution.
You could export the Python file,
and then to upgrade it--
(Laurence) You've got to reconnect
the runtime first.
(Paige) This is true.
So... starting it.
It looks like the requirements--
we can check to see
that we're using TensorFlow Alpha.
And then, like I mentioned before,
all you would have to do
is preface this with the !tf_upgrade_v2,
the name of the Python file
is text_generation.
I want to create an upgrade.
Shift+Enter.
It does its upgrading magic,
and very quickly,
tells me all of the things
that would need to be changed
to make it 2.0 compatible
and creates that file for me
off to the side.
So, now, if I wanted to run this model,
it should be able to train as it would.
So, let's just check
to make sure that would be the case.
(Laurence) I think a lot of the errors
that you're seeing here--
it's more just renamed APIs
rather than breaking changes
within the API--
(Paige) This is true.
So, you can see that you have some renames
and some additional keywords.
Sounds good. And I saw you have
some handy-dandy GIFs in there?
Yes! Absolutely.
Are there any GIFs
for those who don't say "JIF"?
(laughter)
Sorry, I had to work that joke in.
Well, I'm PB,
so peanut butter automatically works.
Exactly. Sounds good.
So, when it comes to upgrade,
there are a few little gotchas in summary,
but hopefully this blog post
and your video
and all of the stuff that we're doing
will help you get around those gotchas.
And even more amazingly,
the community
that you were mentioning before--
we've had such an interest
in testing TensorFlow 2.0
and trying it out against historic models
that we've formed
a weekly testing stand-up,
and also we have a migration support hour
that's being implemented
with the internal support hour.
So, if you have
an external group to Google
that's interested
in upgrading your models,
please join the testing group,
and we can get you situated.
And a lot of stuff that we've seen,
like in Keras models, for example--
Karmel had that great slide
where she was training Fashion MNIST.
- The code is the exact same.
- It's exactly the same.
So, while there might be
stuff changing under the hood,
a lot of the surface-level code
that you're going to be writing
in Keras, at least, isn't changing.
If you've used Keras,
you're probably
not going to have any problems.
So... good stuff.
So, shall we move on to the next question?
- Yes!
- I know we could talk about 2.0 all day.
Okay, we just mentioned Keras,
and it appears.
So, I guess I could ask you this question.
Hopefully, you know the answer.
"What is the purpose of keeping Estimators
and Keras as separate APIs?
Is there going to be
something native to Keras models
that allows for distributed training
à la train_and_evaluate?"
Okay, so the purpose
of keeping them, I think,
there are many purposes, right?
So, I think for me, the main purpose
that I would like to think of
is one that is because a lot
of people are using them.
And including internal Google teams
that would tar and feather us
if we removed them.
(laughter)
So, when it comes to Estimators,
Estimators are really great
for large-scale training.
Yes!
A lot of the time, if you're doing
a lot of large-scale training,
keep going with Estimators
because they're great!
Because when I started with TensorFlow,
I started with Estimators,
because I couldn't figure out
what a node was in a neural network,
and there were all
these concepts that I had to learn,
while I had this simple Estimator
that I could use
to do a DNN or something like that.
So, they're there for a reason,
and they're staying for the reason.
Keras is one of the things
that, from the point of view
of making life easier for developers,
that we've really been doubling down
on TensorFlow 2.0.
And things like we just spoke about,
the code is the same between 1 and 2,
and it's the layers API,
I think, makes it super simple
for you to design in a neural network,
and then the fact that you can go
low level beyond that--
like define your own layers.
It really allows you to drive stick
instead of driving automatic.
Absolutely. One of the beauties
of Keras and 2.0 is that you have Keras
the way that you're probably
familiar with using it,
and then, if you need to do
additional customizations,
there's a subclassing component.
And then, if you need to go even lower,
then we have something called TF Module,
and we even expose some of the basic,
most core ops of TensorFlow as well.
So, at any sort of level
you want to interact
with the API, you can.
I think there was another part
of the question
was around distributed training.
Sorry, it scrolled off,
so I can't see it now.
But there's something
called distributed strategy
with Keras and TensorFlow 2,
and the whole idea behind that
is to allow you to be able
to distribute your training,
maybe across multiple GPUs
on the same machine,
on different machines,
maybe across TPUs
spread all over the place,
that kind of thing.
So, distribution strategy
is really all about that--
to help you with that.
So, Estimators and Keras,
we love them both,
they're both still there.
Hopefully, this is something
that will help you with that question.
I think we've got time for just one more.
- Absolutely.
- Oh, this is a Paige question!
This is totally a me question.
I am the Python person.
So, "Ask TensorFlow,
when will TensorFlow be supported
in Python 3.7 and hence
be accessed in Anaconda 3?"
So, I can certainly answer the Python 3.7,
and also, I would love to speak
a little bit more about support
for Python going forward.
So, to answer the 3.7 question,
I'm going to bounce over
to our TensorFlow 2.0 project tracker.
These are all of the standing issues
that we have when doing development
for TensorFlow 2.0.
- It's transparent--
- (Lawrence) I see your avatar.
(Paige) Yes, I have filed many issues.
And all of them
are transparent to the public.
So, if you ever want to have context
on where we stand currently,
and what we have yet to do,
this project tracker is a great way
to understand that.
But let's take a look at 3.7.
And there we go.
So, in process of releasing binaries
for Python 3.5 and 3.7.
That's issued 25420--
and it's going
a little bit off the screen--
429.
But you can take a look at that issue
and see that it's currently in progress.
There's not really an ETA,
but it's something
that we want to have complete
by the time that the alpha
or [C] is released.
So, that is wonderful to see.
There's also a website
called Python 3 Statement.
I think it's python3statement.com
Maybe it's .org
There we go, cool!
So, TensorFlow has made the commitment
that as of January 1, 2020,
we no longer support Python 2.
And we have done that with a plethora
of our Python community.
So, TensorFlow, pandas, scikit-learn, etc.
We are firmly committed to Python 3
and Python 3 support.
So, you will be getting
your Python 3 support,
and we're firmly committed to having that.
The nice thing about the issue tracker
is it's not going to be a big--
"Hey, we have it!"--
coming at some random point
in the future.
It'll be a case of totally transparent,
and you can keep an eye
on what we're doing.
And you can see people commenting
and our engineers commenting back.
Like, "Yeah, man,
I totally ran the thing last night,
and it's almost there, one more test."
(chuckles) Sounds good.
Okay, I think that's all we have time for.
So, whatever you do, don't forget
to hit that subscribe button.
Alright, thank you so much,
and thanks for being engaged.
Thank you.
♪ (music) ♪